imagine a group of young girls
the year is 1918 and they're playing
jump rope on the sidewalk
and if we listened closely this is what
we might have heard
i had a little bird and its name was
enza i opened up the window and
influenza
in our last lecture we learned about how
the flu originated in kansas
and was carried to europe in our troop
ships today we're going to learn what
happened when
that genetically altered virus that our
soldiers carried overseas
returned to our shores we're going to
look at the city of philadelphia
as a case study of how american cities
responded to the pandemic
and we'll learn why the flu hit so many
isolated native populations
especially hard
well most authorities think that the
american flu mutated into a
killer in its new european population
and by late summer
this mutant or hybrid strain was poised
and ready to re-enter the united states
re-entry may have occurred august 12
1918 from passengers on the norwegian
ship
the bergens fjord the liner entered to
new york harbor with 200 people
sick four of them had been buried at sea
and all of those sick and exposed people
were so frightened
they ran down the game plague as soon as
it docked and scattered
far and wide into the new york city
population
ms olsen a passenger on the bergens
fjord was one of the first to die in
america
in that second wave of the flu over
half a million americans followed her
into the grave
and this scene was repeated over and
over again
as the flu that america had sent
overseas returned with a vengeance
june 1918 the city of exeter arrived
from liverpool
docked in philadelphia with 28 ill
the victims from the city of exeter were
rushed into strict quarantine
and the city was spared for a little
while
the somali arriving from india with 89
sick crewmen
put ashore at gross island canada in all
of these port cities
all of these cities with large military
installations
they turned out to be the most
vulnerable
boston was an early target and one story
is that a group of 106 sailors in boston
called in sick at the commonwealth pier
26 of them died and the flu spread
rapidly from there
camp devins in boston was especially
hard hit
colonel victor vaughn former ama
president
was among those who were sent by the
army to camp devons to investigate the
outbreak
vaughn saw quote hundreds of stalwart
young men
in the uniform of their country coming
into the wards of the hospital in groups
of ten or more
they're placed on the cots until every
bed is filled and yet others crowd in
their faces soon wear a bluish cast a
distressing cough brings up
blood-stained sputum
and in the morning the dead bodies are
stacked about the morgue
like cord wood
one of the first cases at devons was a
young soldier from the 42nd
infantry he ached so badly that he
screamed whenever anyone
touched him he was misdiagnosed with
meningitis
along with several others in
one single day at camp devon's 1543
soldiers reported sick
needless to say the medical staff was
soon overwhelmed
and then the doctors and the nurses
started to sicken and die
one doctor at devons describes it one
can stand to see
one two or twenty men die but to see
these poor devils dropping like flies
it takes special trains to carry away
the dead
for several days there were no coffins
and the bodies piled up
something fierce it beats any sight they
ever had in france after a battle
from sailors and soldiers in coastal
cities the flu spread inland
following the rivers following the
railroads it ravaged the great lakes
naval training station near chicago
one of the nurses recalls wrapping still
living men in winding sheets and putting
death tags on their toes because it
saved
time and they were utterly exhausted
in her nightmare she wondered what it
would be like to be that boy who was at
the bottom
of the cord wood in the morgue
camp grant near rockford illinois was
jammed with over 40
000 troops and colonel charles hagedorn
who was commander of camp grant decided
to ignore the army regulations against
overcrowding
the camp medical staff objected but they
were overruled
the first soldier reported sick on
september 21st
from an infantry training group that
included officers from
camp devons and within a week he was
joined by
4 102 soldiers
1810 reported sick in a single day
and that same day that the first soldier
died of flu at camp grant
hagedorn ordered a crowded troop train
to leave camp grant for camp
hancock near augusta georgia
he ignored demands for a quarantine of
the camp and hundreds of men were packed
into each car
the flu spread very rapidly on board
that overcrowded train
2 000 of the 3 100 soldiers on that
train got the flu
with a death rate estimated at over 10
percent
well when the death toll at camp hancock
passed 450 men
colonel hagedorn instructed his staff to
clear the building
shut himself in his office and shot
himself
one of the reasons the flu was so
terrifying at that time
is that no one had any real idea of what
had caused it
researchers followed several bacterial
dead ends
in the wake of the 1889-1890 flu
pandemic
dr richard pfeiffer had isolated a new
species of bacterium which he called
bacterium influenzae
also known as phifer's bacillus it's now
known as hemophilus influenzae
and it was thought by many including the
public health service to be the
causative agent
this one comes a little bit too close to
home for me because i nearly lost my
only child to hemophilus influenzae
when he was six months old baby's first
christmas was a rather anti-climactic
event
and when you ask a doctor about the odds
of fatality for any disease and they
can't look you in the eye
you should be very very concerned we
discovered to our horror that this is a
major killer especially of children
and a very dangerous disease but not as
it turned out
the cause of the 1918 flu the bacterium
could easily kill hosts in the lab
but the symptoms weren't quite identical
to those of influenza
nevertheless pfeiffer insisted that he
had found the culprit
and his sterling reputation and his high
standing in the scientific community
managed to convince many of his
colleagues that he was correct
but despite improved culture techniques
the bacterium wasn't always present in
flu victims
and was usually found together with
several other pathogens
by 1919 the bacterial hypothesis had
been rejected
and researchers were concluding that
whatever the cause it must be
viral but that was a very controversial
conclusion because it was based entirely
on negative evidence
the gradual elimination of all the
alternative hypotheses
remember viruses back in 1918 were still
a
big mystery the first influenza virus
wasn't isolated and observed until 1934
and the first flu vaccinations didn't
come along until 1944.
so was the whole thing a fiendish german
plot
maybe german spies had mined boston
harbor with influenza sprouting germs
maybe it was started by germans put
ashore from u-boats setting germs loose
in theaters and other public places
there was no cure even secondary
bacterial infections like bacterial
pneumonia were untreatable
sulfa drugs and antibiotics had not yet
been invented
so medical treatment consisted mostly in
comforting
and whenever possible isolating the
patient in other words
basic nursing treatments included
bleeding
saline or glucose injections enemas
alcohol camphor oil heroin morphine
mustard plasters castor oil sulfur smoke
lard mixed with camphor and chloroform
or my favorite
lard mixed with turpentine that will
cure you or
kill you public health responses
included fumigating trains and buses
and passengers and luggage urging people
to wear gauze masks
campaigns against spitting and sneezing
warnings about public gatherings and a
general prescription of rest
fresh air and reporting cases to the
authorities
folk cures abounded and they included
stuffing salt up children's noses
magic charms wearing goose grease
poultices
hanging little bags of garlic or onions
around your neck something my mom made
me do when i was a very little boy
and gargling with disinfectants snake
oil salesmen were
everywhere by mid-october
the full and tragic potential of the
epidemic had been realized
many american cities and towns were hard
hit with unprecedented mortality rates
families were devastated in all public
life
ground to a halt
william sardo of washington dc says
people were afraid to kiss one another
to eat with one another they were afraid
to have
anything that made contact because
that's how you got the flu
you were constantly afraid you were
afraid because you saw so much
death around you it wiped out entire
families from the time the day began
in the morning to bedtime at night there
was an
aura of constant fear
one ottawa newspaper writes streetcars
rattle down bank street with the windows
open and plenty of room inside
schools vaudeville theaters movie
palaces are dark
pool halls and bowling alleys are
deserted
philadelphia was typical of most big
cities ravaged by the flu
the philadelphia navy yard was booming
the hog island shipyard the world's
largest shipyard with over
35 000 workers had just opened that year
munitions factories midvale steel
baldwin locomotive
the city like many american cities at
that time was
bursting at the seams the war industries
added
300 000 people to the city's population
of 1.7 million
and housing was nearly non-existent
scouts patrolled the city to locate
shelter for new arrivals
boarding houses and apartments were
jammed to capacity with workers on
separate ships
often sharing a single bed
overcrowding inadequate social services
squalid living conditions amongst the
poor
all of these made philadelphia a powder
keg for the flu
city government was so bad at that time
and so corrupt
that lincoln stefans called it the worst
governed city in america
and its machine appointed health
director dr wilner crewson
was honest but inexperienced over
cautious
and in the end completely ineffective
despite frequent warnings despite
mounting military cases
he made no plans for an epidemic he made
no stockpiles of medicine or equipment
he didn't even draw up a list of first
responders of doctors and nurses to
contact
in an emergency the news of the epidemic
raging in boston arrived in philadelphia
too late to put the city on alert and
besides the ama journal had announced in
september that the flu was nothing
special and had quote
already practically disappeared from the
allied troops
september 28 1918 oh life in philly was
great
the biggest local news story was the
ongoing coal miner strike and the
upcoming parade
the liberty lone parade designed to sell
warbonds was to be the biggest parade
in the city's history flu had already
arrived in the city hitting the navy
yard in mid-september
and the day before the parade over 200
fluke cases were reported
123 of them civilian
navy personnel tried to stop the parade
but with no success
morale trumped public health
dr crewson continued to insist there was
no danger of an epidemic
it was only as he called it
old-fashioned influenza or grip
that enormous crowd of several hundred
thousand
were packed together for hours as that
two-mile long parade flowed by
airplanes flew overhead anti-aircraft
guns fired live
shells rigged to explode at a low
altitude
now i had to miss mardi gras parades
this year to record these lectures but i
managed to squeeze in a few parades
before i left
and as i was standing on st charles
avenue watching muses flow down the
street
watching float after float after float i
couldn't think about
all the people with their hands in the
air saying throw me something mister
all i could think about was the liberty
loan parade and looked around to see who
was coughing and sneezing
the flu incubation period is typically
24 to 48 hours
and within a day or two of the parade
several hundred people
fell ill the hospitals began to fill
lines of desperate people formed waiting
to get in offering nurses bribes of a
hundred dollars or more to be admitted
crosby tells us visiting nurses often
walked into scenes resembling those of
the plague years of the 14th century
one nurse found a husband dead in the
same room where his wife
lay with newly born twins it had been 24
hours since the death and the births
and the wife had eaten no food but an
apple which happened to lie within reach
12 emergency hospitals would eventually
open to receive the growing number of
the sick
and dying like most big cities
philadelphia had a severe shortage of
doctors and nurses
850 of them were away on war duty
in philadelphia's general hospital 54
nurses ended up as patients
that's 43 percent of the entire nursing
staff
and 10 of them died
so the call went out for retired doctors
even medical students
all five philadelphia medical schools
closed and sent their third and fourth
year students to help
on october 3rd croissant finally ordered
all schools and churches and theaters to
close and band all public gatherings
most grocers were closed and few stores
of any kind were open
but the closing of the schools and the
churches in particular
further isolated citizens from one
another and contributed
to a growing climate of fear an
editorial in the philadelphia inquirer
asks
since crowds gather in congested eating
places and press into elevators and hang
to the straps of ill-ventilated street
cars
it's a little difficult to understand
what is to be gained by
shutting up well-ventilated churches and
theaters
the authorities seem to be going daft
what are they trying to do
scare everybody to death
shutting down bars and taverns created
some
unusual problems because now
you could only get whiskey at the
drugstore and only with a prescription
so drugstores became crowded with long
lines of people
buying whiskey a few unscrupulous
pharmacists pushed the price of whiskey
as high as
52 dollars a gallon a princely sum
in 1918. so many people took the ferry
to nearby camden because the bars there
were still
open the city of camden had to shut down
all of its taverns to stem the tide of
new customers
who were bearing the flu
and in retrospect the closings were
probably unnecessary
for cities like philadelphia that
shuttered public places the case rate
and the death rate were no better than
for cities that left them open
as the true horror of the flu took hold
philadelphia became a city of the dead
isaac starr a university of pennsylvania
student wrote that the life of the city
had almost stopped absentee rates ran
from 20 to 40 percent
for those businesses and factories that
still remained open
the local press and public health
officials continued to lie to the public
about the epidemic insisting that the
worst was over
and they created a prevailing attitude
of public mistrust of government at
every level in early october croissant
insisted that quote
these deaths mark the high water mark in
the fatalities and it's fair to assume
that from this time until the epidemic
is crushed
the death rate will consistently be
lowered
the next day 428 people
died and the body count kept going
higher
and higher
citizens took the hanging crepe paper on
their doors to show that someone had
died
white paper meant that a child or young
adult had died
black meant that the victim was
middle-aged and gray was used to mark
the death of the elderly
the suburb of west manila a mob of
weeping housewives actually blocked the
car of a local doctor who was making a
house call
and would not let him leave until he had
treated every child in the neighborhood
all 57 of them
so many phone workers were out sick that
calls were limited to emergencies only
bell telephone took out ads in the local
papers to announce that no calls would
be accepted
quote other than absolutely necessary
calls compelled by the epidemic
or by war necessity one such ad
reads telephone service faces a crisis
the situation is one which the public
must meet squarely
800 operators 27 percent of our force
are now absent due to influenza it is
every person's duty to the community to
cut out every call that is not
absolutely necessary that the essential
needs of the government
doctors and nurses may be cared for
crosby tells us that dr croyson
empowered the phone company to cut
service to any customers that made
unnecessary calls
and that about 1 000 people were
actually disconnected for violating that
rule
as the casualties continued to mount
orphans and starving children became a
problem
there was no one left alive to feed them
as the epidemic peaked during the week
of october 16
4597
died 759 of them in a single day october
the 10th
with a severe shortage of undertakers
and gravediggers the bodies piled up
rapidly
prisoners seminary students and
clergymen were pressed into service
and to bury its poorest citizens the
city finally resorted to trench graves
dug by steam shovels in potter's field
some undertakers took to profiteering
raising rates up to
600 percent and some cemetery workers
and gravediggers demanded an extra fee
of 15
or more and even insisted after being
bribed that the customers dig their
family's graves themselves
citizens were left with wooden boxes and
instructed to leave their dead on the
front porch
in some cases the bodies were simply
tossed in a heap on wagons
reminiscent of the play gears in
medieval europe
many people were forced to live with the
dead often for
several days closing them off in a
separate room if they had the luxury
or just wrapping them in a sheet and
leaving them in a corner
citizens became increasingly isolated
huddled behind closed doors
ambulances were supplemented with
private cars police cars
anything with wheels taxi drivers were
pressed into service and to their
infinite credit not a
single taxi driver in philadelphia
refused to carry the sick and the dying
to the hospital
every social agency in the city public
and private
chipped in to help as best they could
without regard to race
or creed or color idol
teachers volunteered in droves along
with nuns and priests
boy scouts firemen policemen and
hundreds and hundreds of private
citizens
archbishop dennis dougherty sent 1 000
sisters of saint joseph out into the
community
to help care for the sick by october the
18th
the worst was over and the emergency
hospitals began to close
on sunday the 27th churches were
reopened and school started the next day
and on the 30th the bars and the
theaters reopened
followed by a noticeable spike in
arrests for drunk and disorderly conduct
as many as 500 000 citizens had been
infected and at least
12 897 had died
and those numbers are very conservative
as thousands of cases went unreported in
the chaos
that had descended on the city and
all across america and the aftermath of
the flu
the fate of the survivors became a major
problem
many families were impoverished with one
or more breadwinners sick
or dead and the flu left behind a world
filled with widows and orphans 21 000
orphans from the flu
in new york city alone
deaths of 15 to 34 year olds rose to 20
times the normal rate in a flu epidemic
so it wasn't just the very young
or the very old who died this time
why did so many more young adults die
we're going to try to answer that
question in our next lecture
more elderly people survive than usual
we think because they might have been
exposed to a similar virus earlier in
their lives
and that initial attack may have been so
mild it wasn't noticed but it left them
with at least
partial immunity to the new related
virus
influenza is a little unusual in that
new strains are
fiercely competitive with one another
and this is an interesting example of
competitive exclusion which we learned
about in our very first lecture
one competitor is so successful it
drives the other
into local extinction the flu
triggers the body's immune response
against any and all strains of the flu
that that person has ever come in
contact with
so an existing strain that tries to
reinfect someone will find the door
already closed and will rapidly die out
as a result
so only one subtype of flu can exist in
the human population
at one time
now as time goes on fewer and fewer
people are creating antibodies for other
forms of the flu so a fresh drain
now has an open playing field competing
strains
usually coexist for a brief period a few
months perhaps
and the only way to trace the path of
the flu is by serological archaeology
what a fascinating field taking blood
samples from various age groups
and examining the antibodies to see what
strains each age group had been exposed
to
and try to link those up with recorded
instances of epidemics or pandemics
the third and final wave followed in
late 1918 and
into early 1919 and the flu at this
point
seems to have gradually mutated into a
weaker strain because the third way was
short it was sharp
but relatively mild compared to that
killer second wave
the final toll was grim estimates of
american dead run to 675
000 and that's out of a population of
only 105
million britain lost 228
000 to the flu the best global estimate
out of 1.8 billion
is 50 to 100 million dead and that comes
from nobel laureate and flu expert dr
mcfarland burnett
naive native populations were especially
hard hit
many isolated populations avoid regular
contact with common viruses
and that leaves them highly vulnerable
in pandemics because they have no
immunity whatsoever
american samoa on the other hand
survived without a single victim because
of its
early and very effective quarantine
australia had the lowest global death
rate also thanks to an early quarantine
at the very end a troop ship with 96
soldiers did finally sneak into port but
by then the virus had weakened
in chiapas mexico 10 of the population
died
in the fiji islands 14 percent of the
population died
in 16 days
in noam alaska out of 300 inuits 176
died and many inuit villages were
completely wiped out
with some villages sustaining 85 percent
casualties
or more over 20 million people are now
thought to have died in india
alone one delhi hospital treated 13
000 flu patients only to watch over
seven thousand of them
die an estimated one-third of the entire
population of labrador died
ococ labrador 266 citizens
only 59 survivors hebron 150 inuits dead
out of 220 and in many rural and
isolated areas packs of wild dogs became
a serious problem
starving dogs often broke into dwellings
to feast on the dead or
on those too sick to fight back the rev
andrew asbo shot over 100 dogs
before he was rescued
the virus killed an estimated 7 percent
of the entire population of russia and
iran
these kinds of epidemics are sometimes
called virgin
soil epidemics everyone on earth
at one time was probably exposed to that
virus
those who survived the infection formed
an immune reaction so in the end
the virus had no place left to go it
couldn't maintain itself
in the human population
well fortunately for the flu virus at
any rate it doesn't need humanity to
sustain itself
birds are its primary host and as long
as the bird populations are healthy
the flu will always find a home
at the height of the second wave victor
vaughn nearly lost
hope he writes if the epidemic continues
its mathematical rate of acceleration
civilization could easily disappear from
the face of the
earth within a matter of a few more
weeks
but by late november of 1918 the crest
of the influenza deaths had passed it
was the worst
epidemic in the history of mankind
many great cities like philadelphia
ground to a halt for several weeks
during the pandemic
and as the city of brotherly love
reminds us these disasters bring out
both the best
and the worst in humanity
so what can we do if this killer virus
returns
in our next lecture we're going to wrap
ourselves in the cloak of sherlock
holmes
we're going to follow the trail of one
of the most curious detective stories of
modern times
the search to recover an intact flu
virus
a discovery that could help prevent the
next pandemic
we're also going to learn how the 1918
flu may have helped to set the stage for
world war
ii by infecting president wilson at a
critical stage
of the peace talks